yeah is it on [ __ ] now yeah you ready
here you go five five four three three
two two one
hi
hi hi
everybody everybody everybody welcome
to another edition of a tiger
[Music]
yeah
we got
dude i don't know dude we have to start
over now because you're laughing at me
dude don't let me just say something
right now dude this is a holiday it's a
holiday edition dude oh yeah i mean this
is about the jesus you're right you're
right so you start over five four three
five five four three two
one
[Laughter]
welcome to the tiger belly podcast i'm
your captain bobby lee
so guys um we have a guest i'm gonna i
don't know always do this
but i'm gonna say his name
he's gonna say hello and then this is
how it's gonna go
he's gonna say hello
and then because it's jesus's birthday
coming soon to theater new year we're
gonna i wrote a prayer
and everyone has to repeat when i do
this you repeat the line
and then when i don't do this let me
talk
but and you you and no one's gonna go
this is stupid
we're not doing this anymore you have to
do it
as long as we do the prayer all right
okay
so our guest tonight
is jimmy oh yang give me a give him a
round of applause is this where i'm
supposed to say hello
i'm nervous now i don't want to yeah
he's sweating say hi now okay hi how are
you i'm good are you a christian uh not
i i don't grow up with any religions but
i'm not against anything then there we
go you know because on our podcast we
believe in the lord
no i'm an atheist
she's like a false statement just baby
we have fans from the midwest now in the
south let's just pretend no okay i'm an
atheist but anyway it's jesus's birthday
and i created a prayer
i do love christmas though and so so
when i do this um you guys just repeat
what i say okay okay but i want to just
you know kind of close your eyes right
holding hands or not no we're not going
to hold hands it's weird
right yeah so here we go all right
dear lord
it's yours
that was rehearsal okay when i do this
close your eyes
i can't feel your finger bro i can't
feel it you know what i didn't think it
through
i didn't think
no laughing but i didn't think it
through okay
so um you can open your eyes okay
i feel safer that way yeah yeah good
good spitting granola i know i know i
know i know but that's because i like it
when it's on it gives it a different
flavor oh all right so ate it
so um you ready yes yeah dear lord
dear lord let your glory penetrate us
let your glory penetrate within and
without within and without
black cubes and shadows will not curse
the pure hearted
shadows without curse
and we will kill and defeat dark whites
and cleanse the south
dark dark whites
south all right
repeat i want to see that line again you
[ __ ] it up sorry we're not suffering
the top no we're going to start from the
top i'm not going to be no i don't give
a [ __ ] i don't give a we're going to do
it quicker i don't give a [ __ ] we're
doing it quicker no laughing do not
question it because this is from the
bible okay
oh it's not from grave of thrones or
anything
serious
you're a guest and i'm going to let you
have that one okay
all right jimmy i'm going to let you
have that one all right because you're
our guest i'm just going to listen and
repeat all right so here we go dear lord
let your glory penetrate us with and
without that's yours
penetrate us
black cubes and shadows will not curse
the pure-hearted
shadows
and we will kill and defeat dark whites
and cleanse the south and we will kill
and defeat dark whites and cleanse the
south the roads are never ending
[Music]
amen amen amen
wow wow so how does that feel jesus was
a you know a creative man thank you you
know you get it yeah i i do now i didn't
i know i see the light now god damn it
you know what i always knew this about
you jimmy huh that you were like i don't
like the dark whites in the south
he wants to close this out yeah yeah
nobody
what is that supposed to mean
what are we used to
fantasy
life is an illusion
it's how you perceive it
wake up
open your eyes
and believe
every day every podcast we do
every day i'm going to create a passage
like that yeah i don't know why i
created that that sounded exactly like
an egg cartoon
that no that's my mantra it's an
original i just made it up i'm going to
say it again fantasy
that's not an english accent yeah it's
like it's not it's steve what kind of
accent it's not supposed to be an
english accent okay it's supposed to be
a different accent from a different land
oh in a different time period at a
different dimension okay oh my fantasy
would you guys okay we're listening is
there an [ __ ] i do do it dude being
serious
come on you read it you read you read it
the way i just said it you read it the
way i just said it fantasy yes
life is an illusion yes it's how you
perceive
wake up
open your eyes
and believe yes
welcome to another
another
welcome to another episode of tiger
belly
i'm bobby and uh we got kalila we got
gilbert and we got pink george pink and
then we got bryce his
cousin brother whatever
nephew and we got my little brother
stevie wiebe in the house
what theme song is that from what movie
[Music]
no no i'm being real i didn't say i
didn't see the repeat after me oh
we're all singing no no no no what movie
is that from
um no no no no um
is it space related yes i know i i can
see it yeah mom my mom watched this yeah
not stargazing
yes would you say independence day
i love that movie welcome to tiger belly
i love that movie so much so close can i
i have some trivia for independence day
okay tell me tell me okay i'm gonna ask
you some questions okay
um
in independence day um
in the movie independence day right
pendants yeah um what what what main
character died
oh my god the wife of the president
spoiler alert all right um let me ask
you this afterwards
who plays this main scientist in air
force
um uh what's it called um jeff goldblum
no let me finish
area 51
the main scientist the guy who escorts
the president in yeah yeah but he's the
main scientist down there oh can you
give me a clue um he's in another sci-fi
show
ah [ __ ]
i know i see his face
from star trek die
in the movie yes how
i don't know
[Music]
hey everybody everybody have a good time
hey everybody everybody hello hey
everybody everybody have a good time hey
everybody everybody hello welcome to the
podcast my name is
bobby we've got gilbert kalila and
george and we're brought to you live
from the sunny beaches of san diego at
the pb bar and grill
everything's great everything's sunny
and everything's positive
i feel great about this week and last
week didn't happen last podcast didn't
happen at all
and um this is a new me and we are white
and we're having fun and we're on the
sunny beaches of san diego and we got
two dollar beer margaritas on sale
and today i want to start off with a new
segment i like to call learning stuff
everybody likes to learn stuff do they
not yes do they not raise their hands if
you like to learn stuff
and i want to talk to you today about um
colors
colors oh colors like colors you have
primary colors correct what are those
yellow
blue or is red yes it is sir thank you
it is gabriel
that is a primary color 50 but they're
all there i don't know if you guys know
this but there are offshoots of the
colors and
yeah it's they're very specific ones too
you've got um ones that kind of look
gray called like um slate slate gray
yeah i know that's a nice one right old
wall khaki
that's the one but i want to focus on
the browns today okay if you can focus
on the brown colors and my favorite
color of the browns is sandal brown
brown what does that look like and i'll
tell you what it looks like the color of
colelis [ __ ] in the toilet
this is a fun fact the whole time
she didn't flush the [ __ ] toilet i go
into the bathroom and i see a piece of
[ __ ]
that was it was been for so long you
know how it breaks away
it actually gabriel got hard no it broke
away so it was like different floats oh
it's still soft it's pretty soft and
spread it color diffused outwards the
levee broke
look at the lobby bro also that's my
toilet oh so flush it [ __ ]
hey everybody everybody have a good time
hey everybody everybody hello
now listen this is this is another thing
give me a panic i'm sorry it's a good
thing here's another thing okay
good evening
good evening you all
my name is bobby lee now listen
the last podcast i did
was a little crazy because i had no
sleep i thought it was a little wild
um a little i was a little unhinged
for this one i'm going to be more like
this
like pc pc bob lawrence fishburne more
like laurence thank you really good like
laurence fishburn
yeah i want to be more like morpheus
this is morpheus yes welcome
to the matrix where am i
matrix
take the [ __ ] pill now okay bend over
wait what yeah it's a different kind of
movie
um we have tonight
tonight we have
george is still here
for all of us he's white he's a piece of
[ __ ] whoa yeah i mean but he is human
and he's alive
his heart's beating
yeah and he feels things correct yeah he
said thank you sentient yeah we have a
team like a cow
we have bryce in back of me who is uh
dr rapis is like what do you call him
you know i mean we just relax i love you
and then we have
flat-faced
we got flat-faced island [ __ ] hi
lindsay
we got flat-faced island group here
nature yeah this is the matrix yeah
right so i can be racist yeah
okay yeah and we have my beautiful
japanese wife yeah this is japanese
japanese girlfriend i'll take it goloko
okay yeah
okay i'm gonna be myself now because
that was weird
um we have listen guys everyone listen
we you know
the the the sitcom that i'm on the
numbers were out of control
it was really like uh it was beyond my
expectations and i want to credit tiger
belly fans because a lot of you i made
you watch it you did you know a lot of
you dvr'd it and it's a series not just
the episode they dvr'ed it to siri they
dvr'd it to series and god bless you
take care and you know i give you
spiritual gifts
and so i'm going to speak in tongues a
little bit
and you guys are going to get some real
gifts this year watch
there you go i feel reborn yeah if
you're a virgin you're getting laid this
year
if you're broke you're gonna make a
dollar extra a week
[Music]
welcome to another episode of um the
tiger belly i'm your um slap king slept
the captain
admiral
uh emperor
mr lee captain whatever you want to call
me
but i'm the top and the bottom oh [ __ ]
all right everywhere in between i'll
tell you that right now we got um kalila
my girlfriend
my shipmate
i love her
we got flat-faced [ __ ] what's up what's
up flat face
i've never heard what's up what's up
after that don't talk yet because i have
not introduced you
you're already [ __ ] it up all right
number one you [ __ ] with my [ __ ]
mics all right
i love you but let me just do a proper
intro all right
all right okay
i gotta start over now man
tiger belly five four three two one
welcome to another
episode of tag ballet
um
welcome to another episode of tiger
belly
welcome
to another episode
of
everybody
everybody thanks for listening again to
another episode of this podcast we've
got me
we
we've got
gilbert we got george and we've got thin
lips [ __ ] serial killer magoo back
here [ __ ] face magoo and he's like
killing it right now with this [ __ ]
bd [ __ ] killer eyes i love it
and um we have a special guest but
before i even get into that um
you know i i i um i want to congratulate
jay peel jordan peele who is also been
on our podcast he won an oscar last
night so give him a round of applause
for everybody um i texted him and then
he liked my text
so i didn't really get
a response but you know when someone
likes your text
it's not you know it's not like a
response
but it's it's kind of a [ __ ] you but not
yeah you know i mean it's kind of like i
have to respond but i'm not gonna
actually put words in
yeah but that's fine he was busy last
night oscar he probably responded to
keegan though he probably responded to
keegan and ike
barron halts probably but anyway
congratulations jordan i love you i'm
kidding it was really a big deal and i
got really emotional they aired my pilot
my uh trailer for my sitcom a couple
times that's fine um i look pretty good
on television myself but my point is is
this we have um a very special guest now
listen i've asked this guy to do our
podcast many times before but he's
always i'm in [ __ ] canada or i'm
shooting something in france or some
[ __ ]
and i had done his podcast a million
times 10 minute podcast with him brian
callan and um
he just wants me to [ __ ] say his name
but anyway
but before i even say his name though i
want to say this though too is this that
i want to say this too is is that
when i first got into mad tv um this guy
was a senior cast member on the show
and um really i didn't really get a
really good um
response from the senior cast members
except for this guy this guy
um got my number we hung out he was very
welcoming to me
uh i mean he's a good guy
i [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the tiger belly oscar wrap-up
i thought it was something else what
about oh
yeah
well you know what dude you know what
i'm glad that you're here man yeah i
really i'm very happy to be here are you
really though absolutely i've always
wanted to do your podcast and i happen
to be out of town i've never been to
france
you've never been to france that was a
lie yeah that was a lie no i was
probably in it
welcome
everybody hello hello everybody welcome
to tucker belly everybody thank you
bobby
[Music]
um welcome to another edition of the
greatest
is that we're starting this we're the
greatest we're the greatest and the
worst at the same time oh there we go
yeah best one
hey man
i haven't even introduced you yet man
it's the intro i mean i have to get i'm
gonna give you respect
okay
but you know it's not time yet man okay
but don't say nothing no okay
don't even see nothing all right
so we got kalila here we got george uh
look at his fancy hair now because
people recognize him now brad pitt yeah
on the street streets
they go george you're on tiger belly and
now he slicks his hair back
now he's so gross
we got gilbert here my girlfriend kalila
and i you know we have a very special
guest
today and the guest is
in many ways he's our boss oh
in all ways in all ways he's our boss he
owns us and um they we are under his
umbrella
his name is al madrigal give him a round
of applause everybody five four one two
three four five
[Music]
welcome
welcome to another edition
welcome to another episode welcome to
life
welcome enjoy listen
you know live in the moment but also
live in the future and live in the past
it's all around us some deep [ __ ] shut
the [ __ ] up man i'm not even [ __ ]
brought your name up yet man because i'm
telling you right now
you're on my last [ __ ] nerve right
now man
all right you're the one guest that i
got where i get angry with the one guest
i've never been so angry at a guest
before i want to go oh my god i want to
give him a beverage i want to do all
these things right but i just want to
gouge his eyes out as soon as he came
into my [ __ ] place mr fuji's style
that's what i'm saying all right
let's let me get started
you're a nasty mouthful i'm not a nasty
mom
i'm a young christian warrior i don't
you don't talk
you don't talk until i introduce you
okay nobody who knows what the [ __ ] you
are right yeah everybody knows me
i'm big and glad i know i know i know
but just
all right okay do the five four three
again five we can't even five four three
two one
we got
all kinds of things happening now
we got klyla we got gilbert we got me
too
we got
george i forgot his name for a second
and you got your
cousin bryce back from where the [ __ ]
were you into the wild
do i talk now no no no
oh my god my [ __ ] god listen to me
we have a guest okay and um let me know
when i give you countdown people don't
know who not i'm not gonna know who he
is because he is more street cred than
like anything else
are you saying
i'm just saying
that
he's done a lot of work you know for the
people not really for the people for the
people yeah yeah i do
and um i've known him for a very long
time 20 years
you've known me like three addictions
ago
sam
tropilai tripoli tripoli everybody
do you believe in magic
do you believe in me
welcome to um
tiger belly and we're full of magic here
and i appreciate you
that's the thing i want to say this week
i appreciate you
we got me
and that's the most important thing
we do have me [ __ ] their ass yeah robert
young lee that's my middle name guys
young you guys didn't know that is
robert in your i'm not done i have to
introduce first babe sorry okay okay
we got uh
i appreciate you babe uh don't do it all
right
you don't know what to thank you
ow ow ow all right
we got kalila my girlfriend that baby
not her because you've been scratching
me i don't
[Music]
yeah
you're gonna love me
you're a [ __ ]
yeah that's the hound [ __ ]
that's not the ha that's a hound yeah
the hound
first of all [ __ ] off you [ __ ] slime
slime you slide i brought you chicken
[ __ ] chicken let me see something right
now
birds let me say a thing right now right
i start this podcast and i you know that
guest doesn't talk until i [ __ ]
introduce them you [ __ ] know the
rules i've already been a guest though
yeah but
what is my second guess all right okay
well i guess
then you should know better
okay
wow
you can do bomb stuff oh yeah do you do
bottom words like that dude from police
academy brah
that blackout was michael what's it
michael winslow michael yeah yeah he's
so good i got him
yeah that's like the door was that it's
your [ __ ] door
his [ __ ] door is broken yeah his
closet door is broken the screen door is
broken yeah you're a rich actor all
right what the [ __ ] is going on oh you
attacked me on my pocket i'm sorry i
love you introduction come on i'm gonna
do the introduction
[Music]
go
hey man bro i'm singing a song in the
beginning oh i'm sorry you don't
interrupt me until i [ __ ] introduce
you man
my beautiful [ __ ] island queen
from the mud rivers of
the philippines
we've got uh the philippines have mud
rivers we've got two-dimensional face
gilbert can't see me yeah yeah
if he goes to the side he disappears
this is like a line is that a brown line
great character on charlie brown we got
uh
we have right here richard
ramirez he's out he's back knight
soccer's back yeah knight stalker i
actually don't like how he's in the
closet
i know
and we got uh he's an accomplice there's
a girl in here that's like
yeah i accomplished george kemul
that's how you pronounce it
and we got um a very special because
we've had them before this i think this
is the first time we've used no we've
used assa a couple of times but this is
his um fat lando
from i'm not going
you're fat yoda [ __ ] that's who you are
oh yeah you can't even get all loose
skyrockets back
you skyward is like yoda i don't know if
i can
how about we walk together bro it's good
it's good it's good
i asked for it
three times
dude
welcome to tiger belly man bobby lee
that was the belly house
tiger belly i said not to talk until i
introduce you okay i have a [ __ ]
thing i gotta do bro got it got it dude
we got a [ __ ] special guest here man
and i'm really intimidated by this guy
because he raised me um we got paulie
shore in the house give him a round of
applause everybody we got paulie shore
in the house bro why are you making the
face am i allowed to talk now you can
talk now once i introduce you bro so now
it's now you sound like a [ __ ]
mexican hey bro
hey um but before we get started because
i know you're gonna go on the whole
thing like i was your landlord no i'm
not gonna do it i wanna ask your girl a
question yeah yeah what's it like having
sex with bobby for real not jokingly not
like a performance art
situation
where it's uh it's it's a full um
psychological experience no what's it
like for real
like to see does he go down on you and
stuff um yeah he likes it yeah we've we
played
hold on let me finish
you know
asking my girl about that well i just
wanted to know because i think you're
lucky i am yeah oh no thank you for one
time finally somebody knows thank you
you get to happen you get to be next to
him
it's a gift right it's like being with a
human and a pet at the same time you
know what i mean it's like you got it's
like it's just your place and then
there's cats here and then you got bobby
yeah right yeah and he's like a little
five four three two
one i believe in you
do you believe in me
welcome to another episode of tiger
belly i am your captain i am your leader
captain bob
bob lee bob youngly no one knows my
middle name and i just threw that out
there young y-o-u-n-g not y-u-n-g that's
those other gooks
all right we've got
[Laughter]
we've got um
we've got this white
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] right here and i
love him so much man i love you dude i
[ __ ] love you dude george we got
george campbell man we got his [ __ ]
handsome [ __ ] [ __ ] white
cousin or whatever you mean
that guy
we got uh
gilbert golan
golonko
and we have my beautiful princess my
beautiful princess um kelai lagun and i
met her on tinder everyone knows and um
five years deep in a relationship and
it's going well
and wow what a week
what a day
we've got
we got really we got two really special
people in the room right now and uh
you know
we've got
listen listen
a couple of months ago this white guy
george said oh my god fine everything's
good um
said you know have you heard of h3
podcast and i said um vaguely because
you know i don't really know much
okay
but then i googled it and um i knew
immediately after i googled it i go i
have to do it and i did it and i met
these two
ethan and ela right and they're the
they're a married couple
and they they're the leaders of another
cult called the h3 podcast
and i didn't think that they would ever
come to our compound
because that's the compound yeah it
doesn't compare our compound and um but
they did and here they are
give h3 podcast ela and ethan a round of
applause now you can talk yeah
you have to say you have a yeah yeah you
have a bit of a ritual at the start of
these yes and you make the guest very
uncomfortable
because you're very serious like you're
joking but you're serious i'm never
serious because you said don't talk but
then you make it a joke but it's very
serious yeah yeah yeah yeah but i've
seen you do it before too is that part
of your ritual
do you know why i do it is it a power
play i want the power yeah yeah i need
my power on my court
right and i need to win it right okay
but the thing is is this though um i
respect you thank you i really do i you
guys remind me
of us
right you guys are bigger the better the
better you guys are bigger and better
but we're very similar in many ways
right right both asians
we have the same watch
the shark